first of all I want to say how shocked
and saddened I am that three people have
lost their lives earlier today in
Nottingham and that further individuals
have been injured in this tragic
incident my thoughts first and foremost
are with all of those who have been
involved their friends their families
and their communities I want to thank
the emergency services for their rapid
response they're working Round the Clock
to keep people safe and we're incredibly
grateful for all of their efforts the
police are at an early stage of their
investigation right now they've got to
carry out a lot of work to determine the
precise motive behind the the this
incident I'm in regular contact with the
chief Constable of Nottinghamshire
police but I want to take this
opportunity to urge anybody who has any
information about this incident to come
forward and report it to the police
Nottinghamshire police have said they
were working alongside counter-terrorism
police on this is there anything at this
stage to suggest that this could be a
terror related incident
we're in a very early stage of the
investigation we need to allow the
police the time and the space to carry
out all of their operational activity to
determine the motive it's right that
Nottinghamshire police are working with
counter terrorism policing but it's also
fair to say that everybody in all
professionals on the front line are
keeping an open mind as to what the
precise motive might have been
do the police know who they're dealing
with in terms of the suspect I mean do
they know who they have in custody and
do they know who the victims are and
whether there is any link between them
there are some things we do know right
now we obviously know that sadly
tragically three people have been killed
we know that a knife has been used in
some of those killings and a suspect has
been arrested on suspicion of Murder By
Nottinghamshire police